أنت جراح أعصاب ، لذا اشرح كيف يمكن
لنوبة مثل هذه أن تؤدي إلى هذا
الموت المفاجئ ، نعم أنا حزين جدًا ، أعني أن
العائلة قالت إنه مصاب
بالصرع كانت حالة طبية مستمرة
وما نعرفه هو أنه
أحيانًا يكون الصرع  يمكن أن
يرتبط أيضًا بشيء يعرف باسم دعوى
F وهو الموت المفاجئ غير المتوقع في
الصرع ، ومن النادر حدوث حالة واحدة من كل
ألف نوع من الحالات ، ولكن التفكير
هو أن الشخص الذي أصيب بنوبة صرع
غالبًا أثناء نومه يمكن أن يؤدي إلى انقطاع النفس.
توقف عن التنفس أو
يمكن أن يؤدي إلى إيقاع قلب خطير حقًا
مرة أخرى في كثير من الأحيان يحدث ذلك
أثناء النوم ، لذلك من الصعب اكتشاف أنه من
الصعب معرفة ما
كانت العلاقة بالضبط بالنوبة ، لكن هذا
شيء معروف وهو محزن
ولكنه نادر لحسن الحظ  ولكن من المحتمل أن يكون هذا هو
الشيء الذي
نتحدث عنه هنا جيدًا ، فأنت تقول فقط
أنه من النادر مدى شيوع إبسيلون
إبسيلون ، ما الذي يمكن أن يفعله الناس لتقليل
مخاطر حدوث شيء كهذا ،
نعم  أعني أنك تعلم عندما
تفكر في الصرع في الولايات المتحدة ،
فأنت على الأرجح تعلم أن ثلاثة إلى أربعة
ملايين شخص يتعاملون مع الصرع ويتناولون
الأدوية لمحاولة
السيطرة على الصرع يعرفون أن لديهم
هذا التشخيص ، وقد يكون هناك المزيد حتى
من لديهم  لم تتلقَ تشخيصًا رسميًا بعد ،
لكنك تتحدث عن
ملايين الأشخاص مرة أخرى مع SUDEP
وهو الموت المفاجئ غير المتوقع في
الصرع ، وهذا هو الاختصار ، إنه أمر نادر الحدوث ،
لكننا نعلم أن هناك
مواقف معينة تجعلها
محتملة الحدوث  وهناك قائمة
تعرف أن الأشخاص الذين لم
يأخذوا الأدوية اللازمة كما هو
موصوف ، لا نعرف أن هذا هو
الحال هنا بأي وسيلة ، فإن تجنب
النوبات المعروفة يحفز الأشخاص الذين أصيبوا
بالصرع لفترة طويلة في كثير من الأحيان على
فكرة عما  قد تكون بعض المحفزات
، وتجنب تلك
المشروبات الكحولية المهمة جدًا يمكن أن يرتبط بهذه
الأشياء البسيطة مثل عدم كفاية النوم
جيدًا ، لذا فإننا لا نفعل ذلك مرة أخرى  اعلم أنه ليكون
هذا هو الحال الذي يحقق فيه الطبيب الشرعي في لوس أنجلوس ، فإن
هذا سيكون له نتيجة فعلية
من ستة إلى ثمانية أسابيع من الآن ، لكن
هذا ما تعلمه مما قالته الأسرة
من حالته الطبية ، وهذا
نوع من حيث تشير الأشياء
ولكن الدواء  يمكن للدواء أن يوقف
نوبات مثل هذا ، أعني ما يحدث
بالضبط أثناء النوبة جيدًا
عندما تفكر في
النوبات على الدماغ
وتنظر إلى الوظيفة التي
تراها أساسًا انفجار النشاط الكهربائي
في مكان معين في
الدماغ وهو  ما هي النوبة التي تعتمد الآن
على مكان حدوث هذا في الدماغ ،
يمكن أن تحدث أعراض مختلفة ،
لذلك يصعب أحيانًا
إرجاع الأعراض الجديدة إلى النوبة ، ولكن
بمجرد تشخيص شخص ما
وإصابته بنوبة صرع مثل هذه ، فإن القلق بشأن SUDEP
هو ذلك مباشرة بعد
تأثر الدماغ بنوبة الصرع بطريقة
قد يصاب بها الشخص بانقطاع النفس مرة أخرى ، أو تتوقف عن
التنفس أو هذا
الشذوذ في ضربات القلب الذي يمكن أن يكون قاتلاً
وهذا ما هو تطبيق Sood وهو
يتحكم في دواء كين ، نعم ،
أعني أنك تعلم عندما يتعلق الأمر بهذا
التطبيق الذي يتم مقاضاته ، فهو نادر جدًا بشكل خاص
شخص واحد من بين ألف شخص
يحاولون معرفة من هم هؤلاء الأشخاص
و  ألف شخص
وما وجدوه هو أن الأشخاص الذين لم
يتناولوا أدوية أكثر عرضة للإصابة
بالديون ، لكن هذا ليس هو
الحال دائمًا ، فهناك أشخاص فعلوا
كل شيء بشكل صحيح
وتجنبوا مسبباتهم ، وتناولوا أدويتهم
على النحو المنصوص عليه ، لقد كان لديهم سيطرة جيدة
على الصرع طوال حياتهم ومع
ذلك لا يزالون يصابون به مما يجعل هذا
الأمر مأساويًا للغاية مرة أخرى